[Musique]
suite au passage du cyclone Béal sur la
réunion ce lundi la RD 41 route de la
montagne qui relie Saint-Denis à la
possession et fermé aux usagers au
niveau de la route dit malcôé des
travaux de purge sont actuellement en
cours sur cette zone là c'est beaucoup
de de glissement de terrain des chutes
de pierres qu'il faut donc dès qu' il y
a une zone d' stabilité vu par nous par
le BGM c'est qu'on PUGE qu'on le travail
à faire pour éviter que les blocs
instables tomblent donc on fait tomber
par nous-mêmes on dégage la chaussée
sachant qu'il y a d'énormes problèmes
sur le réseau routier un peu plus bas il
y a énormément de de d'arbres de
branches à dégager qui prennent un temps
relativement important aussi là a des 4
il y a 32 km sur 32 km il y a au moins
une quantaine de points des choses
parfois mineures parfois des choses plus
importantes et toute une gamme de de de
difficultés disons pour la remise en en
état de la route en toute sécurité pour
les
usagers le département met tout en uvre
pour que la RD41 puisse être accessible
ce dimanche 21
janvier